San Diego comic-con has revealed some
super special news for the CW's arrow
verse and it's a development we never
thought we'd ever see a familiar face is
donning Superman's cape once again and
he has some feelings about the impending
comeback as part of the festivities of
comic-con 2019 it was announced that the
CW is cooking up a crossover of epic
proportions
former Superman actor Brandon Ralph who
played Clark Kent in the 2006 film
Superman Returns and current Man of
Steel Tyler hoechlin who portrays Supes
in a recurring capacity on Supergirl
we'll both be suiting up as Superman as
part of the arrow vs. upcoming crisis on
Infinite Earths event it's a role Ralph
hasn't played since 2006 - Superman
Returns and at this point is almost
certainly never expected to play again
Superman everyone was in love with him
the announcement first reported by
deadline on July 19th got fans into the
best kind of huff a fast-talking frenzy
that left some commenters already
declaring crisis on Infinite Earths as
the greatest crossover event ever not
long after the news hit the Nets Ralph
took the social media just like the Vans
did to react to his return as Superman I
think it's only fair that I answered
Ralph's tweeted in response to deadlines
post confirming the news saying that he
was honored humbled grateful and still
pinching myself hoechlin who first
slipped into the Superman suits in 2016
for Supergirl expressed his own
anticipation for the forthcoming clash
of the Superman by tweeting at Ralph
let's go brother Ralph answered back
with a punch and a wink emoji as well as
the comments so excited to share the
screen with you as Supes Tyler hoechlin
so fun I'm so ready
Ralph also joked that he was immediately
heading off to the gym to get in tip-top
shape with a crossover though we doubt
he actually needs to considering that
he's been playing superheroes for years
arrow bursts loyals will already
recognize route from his role as Ray
Palmer better known as the atom a role
which he's taken to arrow the flash and
DC's legends of tomorrow on which he's
currently a main player the actor also
opened up to Entertainment Weekly about
his return to the role that put him on
the map as a younger man he admitted
that he initially experienced mixed
feelings about the news before letting
himself feel excited asked about his
outlook Ralph said it's an opportunity
for me to kind of say hello and goodbye
to the character in a way I
get to the first time being a young
individual at the time 24 25 I thought
oh we're gonna do this I'm gonna do this
for years and make multiple movies and
then that of course didn't happen so I'm
just you know very honored to do this
one last time route than declan's
eagerness about playing Dueling Superman
is nothing compared to the reactions of
their fans
one of whom tweeted the fact that both
of you will be sharing the screen as
Supes is blowing my mind can't wait to
see you both back in the red cape
another said that the news was the best
thing they had heard yet from this
year's Comic Con even more incredible
than the surprise Top Gun maverick
trailer Tom Cruise dropped on Thursday
according to that fan I was buzzing like
a happy bee over the top gun trailer
then this Brandon Ralph's news drops
into my hive like a dollop of sweet
unpasteurized honey yes yes yes best DC
news in ever what makes the news of
Ralph's return to the Superman role so
exciting is that many thought it would
never be possible the idea of seeing
Ralph is kal-el again was pretty
unthinkable after Superman Returns
failed to generate the kind of box
office that studio Warner Brothers
pitchers needed to greenlight a sequel
taking in just over 391 million dollars
worldwide
that's not much compared to the other DC
Comics based fair from WB which has
tended to scoop up anywhere from around
750 million dollars globally on the
lower end to over 1 billion dollars at
the top while Ralph did pick up praise
first performance Warner Brothers
decided not to pursue more films with
him in the role the studio wind up
rebooting the character seven years
later in 2013's Man of Steel the film
that started the DC extended universe as
we know it it's unknown which
installments of the 5 episode crisis on
Infinite Earths event route and hoechlin
will appear on much like previous
crossover events in the arrowverse the
expansive story is set to once again
bring together the cast of The CW
superhero series this time around
including arrow bat woman the flash
legends of tomorrow and Supergirl
even without the Superman news it's
clear that the event will be the biggest
one in the arrowverse thus far spanning
two months of real time with three
episodes of the crossover scene release
in December and two more to follow in
January 2020 the crossover story is
likely to follow or at least draw
inspiration from the DC Comics storyline
of the same name in which the heroes
fight against the nefarious anti-monitor
with the help of alternate versions of
themselves from different universes with
that story as the jumping
point crisis on Infinite Earths was
already shaping up to be unlike anything
arrowverse fans have seen prior to this
announcement but now it's simply superb
to superman's at the same time it's just
the icing on the cake and we're glad
that Ralph thinks the news is as sweet
as we do check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superheroes
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]